un départ à contrecoeur ses habitants du
district de latchine obligé de plier
bagages à faire tasser vaut dans une
voiture route enneigée
le chemin vers l'arménie sera rude
nous avons laissé tout ce que nous
avions à la maison nous ne prenons que
le bétail nous avons laissé toutes nos
affaires à la maison après les faits que
nous vivions là mais comme ce sera
donnée aux azerbaïdjanais et bien nous
quittons le village nous emmenons le
bétail à goris en a remis les oui c'est
notre vie un accord de paix à respecter
sous l'égide de la russie après le
district de cale bajard celui d'agdam
c'est au tour de la chine de passer ce
mardi sous pavillon azéri
mais le chef de ce dernier district
souhaite se montrer patriotes jusqu'au
beau chercher 15 michel aulas le drapeau
de l'artac flotte sur le bâtiment de
l'administration
je serai là tant que le drapeau flottera
pour l'instant je ne peux pas dire ce
qui va se passer dans quelques heures
nous avons eu une information officielle
selon laquelle berne d'or agave noé sus
trois localités du district reste
arménien ce qui signifie que la vie de
la population arménienne serait possible
là-bas dans le sud le corridor de
latchine des plus stratégiques
une bande de terre de 5 km qui relie
l'arménie le haut karabagh la présence
militaire et donc renforcer les soldats
russes du maintien de la paix
multiplient les contrôles routiers à
proximité notamment des postes de
l'armée azerbaïdjanaise
tout est calme et tranquille ici nous
suivons toutes les règles de l'accord
nous n'avons aucun problème avec les
soldats de la paix russes et en même
temps les citoyens arméniens utilisent
la route librement nous décrétons aucun
problème
[Musique]
au total dans ce conflit les
séparatistes du haut karabagh ont
rétrocédé sept districts à l'azerbaïdjan
près de 2000 soldats russes ont été
déployés depuis le cessez le feu
dimanche deux premières unités médicales
militaires sont arrivés à stepanakert 60
médecin militaire russe et un hôpital de
campagne pouvant accueillir jusqu'à 40
personnes ont été installés au coeur de
la capitale du haut karabagh pour aider
les habitants restant à panser leurs
plaies